I think you know one foot one step at a
time and everyone started found me in
the near future
a royal baby is on the way in spring
2019 a kensington palace spokesperson
confirms to ET Megan Marko and Prince
Harry are expecting their first child
together according to the palace Megan
has passed her 12-week mark of pregnancy
and is in good health
we're told Megan's mom Doria Raglan is
very happy about the baby news quote she
looks forward to welcoming her first
grandchild as for whether her dad Thomas
Markel knows the palace declined to
comment according to multiple reports
the couple broke the news to the royal
family at Princess Eugenie and Jack
Brooke banks wedding last Friday she was
in New York City it's a new chapter but
it looks like we won't see the Dutchess
of Sussex slowing down soon ET has
learned Megan will not adjust her royal
tour schedule with Harry as they travel
for two weeks to Australia New Zealand
Fiji Tonga and are expected to touch
down in Sydney Australia on Tuesday
despite a risk of Zika virus on the
islands of Fiji and Tonga Megan will
continue to embark on the tour as
planned
however Prince Harry will visit the Fiji
war memorials solo both of us have
passions wanting to make change change
for good life will change for the couple
as they welcome a new addition Megan and
Harry's future child will be seventh in
line to the throne but will not hold an
official royal title while the couple
remains tight-lipped about the gender of
the royal baby
the 37 year old former actress also
managed to keep her growing baby bump a
secret here are a few times Megan
strategically masks her impending
pregnancy back in September she wore a
royal blue peacoat and cut off
high-waisted skirt at an event honoring
the release of
a community cookbook here is Megan
rocking an LBD with a well-placed wide
black belt at the opening Oceania
exhibition at the Royal Academy of Arts
earlier this month the Duchess took her
biggest fashion risk by sporting a loose
green button-down and fitted green
leather skirt which appeared to show a
tiny baby bump and as Megan and Harry's
public announcement drew closer she
offered no hint of a shape wearing this
wide navy coat dress to witness princess
Eugenie's nuptials icing on the cake
yeah there's one accessory the mom-to-be
already has waiting for her child back
in 2015 Megan told Hello magazine about
the cardi a French tank watch she wants
to pass down to her future daughter that
holds a special meaning to her quote
when I found out suits had been picked
up for our third season which at the
time felt like such a milestone
I totally splurged and bought the
two-tone version the watch retails for
about 1,600 bucks
Megan revealed she has an inscription
engraved on the back that reads - mmm
from mmm
[Music]
you